So Raid 0 uses a technique called
striping to improve performance.
So if we have one disk,
it will have a Track 0,
Track 1, Track 2, et cetera,
and the problem is that
while the head is positioned to read
Track 0, it cannot be reading Track 1,
and also its very far away from
all of these other tracks.
So what happens is really, we have to
serialize accesses to all of the tracks.
If we need to read Tracks 0,
17 and 27, we will have to decide
in what order we access them.
But for each of these accesses,
we move the we read the track.
We move on to something else.
So we cannot get more performance
than just reading one track at a time
at the current rotational
speed of the disk.
What rate 0 does is it
takes two disks and
makes them look like this one disk,
by putting the original Track 0 here,
Track 1 here, Track 2 here,
Track 3 here, and so on.
So the idea is that now each of
these tracks is called a stripe now,
and we're going to put stripe 0 really
here, stripe 1 here, and so on.
So Track 0 of the first disk gets
Track 0 from the overall large disk.
Track 0 here, however,
gets the stripe zero.
So instead of calling this tracks,
we call them stripes to avoid confusion
between what's a track on a physical
disk and these things that
really are tracks that would belong
to a fake disk that we don't really
have because really these two disks
are pretending to be this one disk.
As far as performance is concerned,
we get twice the data throughput
if we have two discs.
Why?
Well, because, while the first
disk is reading some data,
the second could be reading data, too.
And because controllers and
buses today are faster than
what the disk can get to.
Effectively we can transfer
twice the amount of data
assuming that those disks
are actually transferring the data.
You can be unlucky and
all the data you want is on the stripes
that are placed in this disk in which
case you're going to get only
the data throughput of a single disk.
But on average we tend to get almost
twice the throughput of a single disk
by splitting the data
across two disks like this.
As far as latency is concerned,
because we have more throughput
we get less curing delay.
Normally we would be able to handle
requests one at a time here.
Now we can actually in
parallel do two requests.
So in the queue,
we get faster to the requests
by basically handling
previous requests faster.
But what about reliability?
Unfortunately, it gets
worse than one disk.